[Music]
good evening I'm Alexandra is the
executive director at the long now
foundation I just wanted to update all
of you on on a bit on the funding for
this program as well as the funding for
our other programs but luckily just
yesterday thanks to the most recent
sponsorship by Kamiya wood as well as a
renewal from Peter Bauman who's here
tonight we crossed over the 500,000
threshold for the interval funding and
and for this program as well so thank
you all it has been a long road to get
here how many people have been to the
interval over in Fort Mason nice
awesome well the rest of you go we are
we're doing more speaking series another
speaking series there on Tuesday
evenings and I think we have the next
three or four Tuesday's already booked
out with some really really amazing
talks and book launches for I think the
next one is the future Declassified with
Matthew Burroughs and after that Ariel
Waldman on citizen the futures of
citizen space it ought to be really fun
the other thing that of course in the
tradition of all good Kickstarter's we
we now have stretch goals and the the
thing the things we haven't paid for yet
are our robots we have two robots so one
that has already been built in
Switzerland that's going to be drawing
on the that can draw on the chalkboard
and one that can make bespoke gins out
of 15 ingredients so if you take the
Juniper out of that that's 14
ingredients of 14 factorial I think is a
different Ginny today for 238 million
years
so you have that long to get there
before you run out of interesting gents
tonight's long short as you many of you
know we do a short film about long-term
thinking before a lot of these and
Andrew and our office suggested the
other type of synthetic biology some
sculptural work done by teo johnson
johnson and i had a chance to meet him a
while ago and he was nice enough to
unearth some of the very best archival
footage of his strand beast work and we
found this other archival interview by
Romero and the sound quality is not
great but the content for tonight's talk
is dead on so we're including it enjoy
[Music]
my name is teri Johnson and I work since
22 years I tried to make new forms of
life and these forms of life are not
based on protein like the existing forms
of life but I based my my basic material
this is plastic tubing which we use in
our four tables in houses
at the beginning was that I used to be
received because it was cheap and so
available
I noticed while making it how beautiful
it became how willing the material is as
you noticed if you heat it you can do
anything with it you can make pistons of
it so it's really a new building
construction material of life just like
protein
so I tried to make everything of this
blessing to banana that became his
culture of animals which could walk and
these animals they don't have to eat
they get their energy from the winds and
I want them to live on the beaches in
Holland
my project is not only about life in
general it's also more or less about my
own lives and I was born almost on the
beach from my room I could look over the
sea and I spent my youth a lot on this
Beach at the beginning of my life I and
still I live on the beach so it's also
my personal life which plays a role in
this
life itself gives me inspiration I'm
very surprised like well we all are
surprised that we are here I guess I am
surprised every day that I exists I
wonder where it all came from some I
studied the evolution theory
that was a Darwin could give me is by
inspirator
the our social structure is based on the
social structure of animals we have lots
of habits which come from the monkeys
also I feel did I'm a monkey
and just an animal with all my strange
habits
I tried to solve the secrets of life I
know I won't solve anything but at least
you can solve some secrets to have more
insight in how it all came that we are
here the strength thing of this animal
this reduce humanity somehow said they
seduced humanity to take care of her
so I hope that once you and I are gone
there our children and grandchildren
will take care of the strongest
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening I'm Stuart brand they say
it's supposed to be a biological century
last century was we were hearing was
gonna be a digital century and that
turned out to be the case but what
happens with these things where we name
a technology is going to be dominant
people start focusing on the technology
and that's what gets the news but if you
want to know where the technology is
going and you fall onto if you want to
affect where the technology is going
don't focus on technology focus on the
people especially focused on the
youngest of the people who are either
interested in the technology or might
become interested in the technology and
if you watch what they're doing
especially in the pre commercial world
in the people are just trying stuff
trying things that appeal to them is
before there's customers before this
manufacturing that's just trying stuff
then you'll know where the technology is
going and if you want to engage where
the technology is going you engage with
those people that's drew endy strategy
and he's here to talk about it true
I agree with Stuart and so I found a
video online today to answer this
question and I'd like to share it with
you for a few minutes
[Music]
hi I'm and I'm the team leader
for the Cornell University genetically
engineered machines team when the
undergraduate student run team that uses
synthetic biology as a platform to
develop innovative new tools to help
with the many needs of Industry the
environment and the economy each year we
competed I Jeff an international
synthetic biology competition in which
over 200 teams from across the globe
participate each T presents a novel
budget through field synthetic biology
to a panel of judges after several
months of research it's a wide range
definition
[Music]
in 2012 we constructed a field of global
biosensor safety-net gatech arsenic in
wastewater this project place for the
top 16 internationally so with all his
best solution to an oil sands problem in
the Canadian oil sands ownership an
issue in 2011 corn Elijah developed a
cell-free method of synthesizing complex
bad emotions called the bio factory so
on the best manufacturing ward at the
International
[Music]
we were inspired to work with fungi by
eco beta a company in upstate New York
that produces a biodegradable styrofoam
substitute from fungi such as Ganoderma
[Music]
[Applause]
according to the Environmental
Protection Agency styrofoam takes 500
years to degrade and generates over 50
hazardous chemical byproducts making
disposal a difficult and costly task
the EPA has identified styrofoam as the
fifth largest creator of waste currently
the material is banned in over 200
cities across America this list of
locations will soon include New York
City and the state of Massachusetts
we're working with the Chinese medicinal
mushroom Ganoderma lucidum no identity
before has worked with a mushroom and
even in the overall scientific
literature there's very little work
genetically modifying mushrooms so this
year what we'll be doing is building a
toolkit of genetic parts to make
genetically modifying mushrooms in the
future much easier
there are hundreds of these videos you
can find them online on YouTube and
where you wish and what's happening here
is you have self-organized distributed
teams of students around the world
deciding that they'd like to partner
with biology to make something to solve
a problem as they conceive it wherever
they are they come together through this
activity called high gem international
genetically engineered machines
competition and if you decide to do that
here's how it works
in the spring you register to
participate in the competition in 2013
there are over two hundred teams
participating those teams prepare to do
work during the summer when they're not
in class as a full time research
activity or entrepreneurial activity if
you will to help them with their work
they're sent a distribution or
collection of biobrick parts thousands
of pieces of DNA that had been made by
students in previous year's competitions
and shared if you will via given get
philosophy philosophy run by the iGEM
foundation you get the parts you work on
what you want maybe you make some new
parts maybe you'll give those parts back
for the next year's competition in the
meantime when the fall starts to show up
hopefully you've done something
hopefully you have something to show for
it hopefully it even works and you
prepare to come to the Jamboree which
this year will be held at the end of
October in Massachusetts and you can see
what all the other teams did and compete
for prizes so that's I John it's run by
this organization public benefit charity
spun out of MIT
directed by Randy red Berg and operated
by Megan Lazaro so you can see they're
supporting collegiate teams now high
school teams and so on so forth why does
this exist this is important because it
gives you the framing for where the
people came from and where the people
might be going and I don't want to
represent that I know where things are
going but I want to give you the history
so you can see where the uncertainty
might lie we've got this planet that
were part
and it's got some biology on it if
you're familiar with the catalogue
there's a whole earth genome maybe it's
about 10 to the 35th base pairs of DNA
George church things a little bit more
nobody's really counted but what's
interesting about this number is if you
think about our capacity to sequence DNA
this century we should be able to
sequence every base of DNA on the planet
this material is associated with systems
that are capable of processing matter
living matter to make a diversity of
things sometimes it's natural sometimes
it's directed by humans this is the
explicit weaving of the rubber plant
roots to make double-decker suspension
bridges that grow in place in India how
could we as people partner better with
biology to make stuff one struggle is
when we look at natural biological
systems they're hard to figure out this
is the sequence of a genome of a
bacterial virus 40,000 base pairs of DNA
could you tell me how it works
this is the schematic of an electrical
circuit unlike most human designed
electrical circuits this electrical
circuit has been evolved by a genetic
program a computational algorithm
mimicking evolution I went into an
electrical engineering professors office
at MIT Jerry Sussman's office and I
asked him could you please help me to
reverse engineer this I thought if I
could learn how to reverse engineer
simpler systems electrical systems that
might help me to reverse engineer
natural genetic systems that have also
been evolved and Jerry took a look at
this the first thing he complained about
was the quality that print out wasn't
very good
and then he said you know I'm not quite
sure where did you get this from
who designed this and I said nobody
designed this this was evolved by John
cosas working on his genetic programming
platforms and at this point he said get
the hell out of my office which was
atypical for my interactions with Jerry
I said why is that Jerry and he says
well you know this thing wasn't
optimized to be easy for me to
understand let alone explain it to you
why do evolve systems look the way they
do how do they work what does this do
well this one apparently takes the
square root of an input voltage what if
natural biological systems are hard to
understand because they weren't
optimized by evolution to be easy to
understand maybe we want to think about
making things one of the best
biophysicists in the world is Mykel oh
it's now at Caltech and he was one of
the first people to begin to turn the
corner and put together the molecules of
life sort of the humpty-dumpty problem
to make new things
his famous repressilator which is a type
of oscillator operating inside bacteria
this movie made over a decade ago this
was the beginning of a sort of sense
that we could think about systematically
engineering integrated genetic systems
and get them to work now it's very messy
it's barely working but you can begin to
imagine getting good at this
nevertheless Mike's the best it turns
out and it took him years to get this
simple thing to work if I was an
electrical engineer I go get a 14 pin
out hex inverter and have a ring
oscillator working in a few minutes you
know another project that's
state-of-the-art if you will is to
approach a disease like malaria and say
maybe we could make this drug
artemisinin for curing malaria not in a
plant that takes a long time to grow but
perhaps we could reprogram the
metabolism of yeast to do it and some of
these folks are in the room tonight this
was done at Berkeley and in Emeryville
at UC in Amherst and so on you know the
thing of it was it cost about twenty
five million dollars of R&D and that
paid for over a hundred person years of
PhD level expertise to retune this
Baker's East metabolism to make this
chemic
and he might say that's not so bad to
make a drug for treating a bad disease
like malaria except that resistance to
this drug is occurring so we can
anticipate need to do this project again
and again and again and again and I bet
we could come up with the money but
what's really gonna be hard is actually
keeping the team together because it's
so difficult to do the work these types
of biotech projects are Herculean all of
this is the landscape in which I gem get
started we don't understand the natural
systems they don't appear to be
optimized to be engineer bull and when
we do biotech projects it's crazy hard I
can keep going you know what could I
imagine doing with biotechnology well
I'm going to posit we haven't even
gotten very good at that if I have an
object like this in my front yard what's
it good for
it grows pine cones in Menlo Park we
grow 500 pounds per person per year of
garden clippings which come off the
plants and go into the compost heap and
but in a town of 32 thousand citizens
that 16 million pounds of matter
compiled from the atmosphere every year
16 million pounds of matter is quite a
lot of self-assembling nanotechnology as
an engineer I do nothing with that if
the world's chip supply is a billion
chips per year and each processor weighs
a gram that's about 2 million pounds or
one-eighth of the manufacturing capacity
of Menlo Park maybe I could imagine
growing a cash crop of computer chips on
my pine tree take a long time more time
than I have maybe there's a different
way to do it but you see what I mean we
haven't imagined what most of biology
might make and part because it's too
hard still why is it still hard pop quiz
not many people are working to make it
easy business or politics our cultural
systems select for solving problems
right away and not making it easier it
could be actually physically impossible
to get good at engineering biology the
damn stuff could be too hard to work
with is so different summer combination
is above something else I don't know
well let me give you my anecdotal
evidence
before my time there was a paper
published by the president of MIT
talking about let's start a new major in
biological engineering at MIT this is
1939 it's just a few years after the
Rockefeller Foundation started investing
in physicists and others working in
biology leads to molecular biology and
genetics dammit this didn't get started
so when I was at MIT we weren't
preparing to celebrate the 70th
anniversary of a successful program hmm
how about out west well Cal started a
program in bioengineering this is the
textbook from the introduction to
bioengineering course offered by the
faculty at Cal when we were starting
things up at MIT I said why don't I take
this book and steal the solution for the
undergraduate major since they've
already figured out that's what good
engineers will do if the problems
already solved you reuse the solution
started reading the book I didn't have
to read very far in the third sentence
of the preface it reads when we talk
about by engineering here we're gonna
exclude genetic engineering that is
systematically changing phenotypes by
changing genotypes as a declarative non
sequitur that's not further revisited
maybe maybe most of there's a good book
there's lots of good things you know
medical imaging x-rays artificial joints
right things you would want are in this
book but not genetic engineering
this is decades after San Francisco
helped invent genetic engineering by the
way wasn't any better at Stanford
maybe the engineers haven't been working
on it how about politics well I'm gonna
submit for consideration that
biotechnology is a technology of last
resort if we could solve problems if I
could cure disease you have with nuts
and bolts or some type of technology
that I know how to use reliably I do it
it's gonna be cheap is gonna work when I
go to solve problems with biotechnology
they're sort of my last chance to solve
the problem cured the disease right away
make the drop in biofuels a right fix
the environment do something desperate
for example I found myself testifying
before the Energy and Commerce
Commission in the house and the ranking
Republican the Honorable Joe Barton from
Texas what would he want what would be
his miracle application of US
biotechnologists
what would a politician whine oil money
votes could you engineer genome that
would predispose folks to vote
Republican it's a smart question and
then maybe remember that third option
perhaps it's physically impossible to
take living matter and make it engineer
engineer bull and the way we're familiar
with right this stuff right it's
different it's actually just different
I've got self mixing molecular systems
it's kind of like this weird goopy jello
and that's because there's atomic scale
thermal noise just Schrodinger was
totally freaked out about that these
things copy themselves right it's not
like these objects here which we have to
make a replacement object directly copy
itself that's incredible and when you
look inside them it's not like we're
stamping out the same features you know
the transistor over and over and over
get a billion times almost every
molecule is different or could be
modified or combined with other
molecules another way so that things are
just qualitatively distinct the
heterogeneity and complexity is beyond
what we're familiar with them oh by the
way if you actually make any incremental
progress in the affirmative in response
to this question everybody freaks out
and maybe it's impossible this is the
context that sets up I gem all right
even though we have huge successes in
the initial deployment of genetic
engineering and huge controversy we
don't have a lot of systematic
engagement within the educational or
research universities around this puzzle
of could we make living matter fully
programmable or fully engineered but
what would that even mean DARPA
commissioned us is the Defense Advanced
Research Projects Agency the agency in
response to Sputnik established to
prevent technical surprise and now their
mission is to create and prevent
technical surprise they commissioned us
they commissioned us to explore this
question of could you make biology easy
engineer and how would you do it and you
can find a full briefing I gave to the
director of DARPA in October 2003 here
this resulted from 18 months of study
with the smartest people we could find
to think about this question how could
you make biology more engineer able Carl
pabo here in the room was one of the
biologists brought to the table you know
another person we brought to the table
is Lynn Conway not a biologist an
electrical engineer Lynn was responsible
for the VLSI electronics revolution in
the 1970s working with Carver Mead you
know when he talked to Lynn about
electronics and how he got better at
engineering electronics the one thing
she said that hit us over and over and
over again was two words together go
meta don't think about making one thing
easier think about making the process of
engineering easier for whatever it is
you're trying to work with now this is
the course that she ran in 1978 where
she brought students together at MIT to
get access to silicon wafer fab through
new tools that made it easier for people
who weren't associated with the fab
itself to design electrical systems that
could then be built and have a good
chance of working on the fab line so we
worked and worked and worked and we came
up with three recommendations and I'll
make it simple for you we focused on
this cycle the core of the engineering
cycle no matter what type of engineer
you are or what you're working with
once you figure out your intent what
your goal is you've got to design
something you got to build it you got to
test it you got a debug it and go around
the cycle over and over and over again
and so we asked how could we get better
at this for living matter and we said
three things number one get better at
printing DNA DNA synthesis so that you
could separate design from construction
somebody was an expert architect for
this wonderful space somebody else was
an expert builder to make the space and
they specialized in design and
construction let's do that for biotech
let's develop standards as you'll see
later that result in coordination of
labor enabling people to share that's
going to become essential and then we'll
borrow this idea from computer
programming called abstraction could we
organized functions in a way they were
allow us to manage by a complexity so
you go back and read what we wrote in
2003 we said these three things separate
design and time with fat with synthesis
coordinate labor with standards and
manage complexity with abstraction I
think it's important to write things
down so you could hold yourself
accountable to what you were thinking
so then what well 2003 was a tricky time
to propose getting better at engineering
biology in the United States were
operating in a security regime we had
the anthrax attacks just 24 months
previously there's not a lot of great
expertise or familiarity with
biosecurity at the time and perhaps even
still today and so the briefing and
everything that might normally lead to
systemic Public Programs and doing this
just the opposite these things went over
like a lead balloon we went back to
campus we tried to figure out what to do
and we observe something although we
didn't have a lot of money well we had a
lot of was students they were a
renewable resource and it's interesting
you've got to imagine being a teenager
matriculating at a top engineering
university and the university is
representing to you that you could
potentially earn a degree in biological
engineering if your teenager it's the
21st century what do you expect to learn
all you have to do is listen and the
students would say things like I would
like to cure diseases I would like to
make the environment better and go fine
fine everybody wants to do that why
biological engineering and then they
would say well I think you could teach
me how to design living organisms if I'm
an electrical engineer you teach them
how to design a build a computer surely
a biological engineer could teach me how
to design a life form and Spore the
video game was about coming out or
something and then I want to debug
existing programs right so that you
teach me something about that this is
what the renewable resources presenting
created a big problem we didn't really
know how to teach that and maybe we
still don't know how to teach that
perfectly well that's absolutely true
and so we were faced with this question
do we go away for fifty years or however
long it takes and figure everything out
and then come back and teach or do we
admit to our students we don't know how
to teach this but it's important to
learn and maybe we could work together
we took the second approach and one of
the reasons we're able to do that is MIT
had a and still does has this wonderful
activity called I AP there's a fall
semester and that ends in December and
then the spring semester doesn't start
until February what the hell happens in
January whatever anybody wants some
people go to Hawaii but most people stay
where it's cold right and anybody can
offer a class on anything so we decided
Tom Jerry Randy and me to offer a class
on blinkers we're gonna engineer genetic
blinkers and we had went and talked with
in Conway how did she do it with the
silicon and okay well it's gonna be
essential that we don't spend any time
in the laboratory we're only gonna allow
the students to design genetic
oscillators that's it and then we'll pay
somebody else to build and test them now
there's a really nice gene synthesis
company at the time in Bothell
Washington started by an MIT alumni John
Mulligan is called blue heron and they
gave us the low low price of printing
student DNA of $4 a base pair and I was
able to raise $80,000 and that was
enough to pay for 20,000 base pairs of
DNA printing for the student designs so
we said okay we can do this we got some
students remember for later that lady
sitting right off left Center in the
middle we ran into a problem when the
students finished their design work
instead of adding up to 20,000 base
pairs of DNA the designs added up to
30,000 bases of DNA it was going to cost
me 120 kilobytes or $120,000 to print
the DNA $40,000 really did not have tom
night here in his earlier career as an
electrical engineer had come up with
something that allowed us to solve this
problem
idempotent vector design for standard
assembly of BioBricks this is Tom's
invention of the idea of standard
biological parts or biobrick parts and
with hindsight you know it's a
technology of a decade ago it's not
perfectly modern but for the time it was
absolutely radical it was a way of
organizing genetic objects such that the
simple operation of combining one object
with another object was the same for any
two objects he wanted to put together
and once you put two objects together it
resulted in a composite object that
could be treated like any other object
that's what idempotent means the
operation produce something you could
reuse in the same operation and this had
to do with restriction sites and the
boundaries around DNA and there's lots
of problems with that but damn it was
better than nothing and what that meant
was when this other guy Randy observed
Tom's invention and our budget problem
he then made a leap he said you know
that team over there with their
oscillator design they need a DNA
binding protein in it but I don't know
what that is because he's the guy who
did tcp/ip a long long time ago in the
butterfly processor but he just I just
know that that thing they piece of DNA
they need over there that's the same
piece of DNA this other team needs if
only there was some way for them to
share the part we'd only have to build
it once we just have to get the people
to cooperate we have to get the people
to coordinate labor and share and so
randy said hey everybody i have plenty
of numbers i started handing out numbers
for people's different DNA widgets and
then we looked up which numbers encoded
the same stuff and that resulted in cost
savings instead of $120,000 of DNA
printer it was fifty seven thousand
dollars I have now thirteen thousand
dollars under budget we hit the print
button and guess what it took me six
weeks to hit the print button because
there is no print button in 2003 I have
to manually cut and paste each sequence
of DNA into some horrific web form and
then it wants me to triple check it in
each time the sequence is coming back at
me as raw text it's just t-80 icg icg
CAC TIG I'm on I hope I got it right
because it's four dollars every letter
is for dollar
took me six weeks to hit the print
button it took six months for the DNA to
come back because we broke the factory
the things the students are designing
they couldn't build half of them we had
to debug that oh another decision what
do we do
we decided who cares let's just teach
the class again we're having a good time
it was really an important decision
right cuz October we taught the class in
January is now October we just gotten
all the DNA back we weren't gonna have
time to test anything so we tied aside
teach it again
and this time instead of blinkers we
call it polka dots that I found earlier
today the actual advertisement we put up
around the campus tired of evolving make
new friends right come come work with
that right and we got some more students
see the students we got four more
students we had twenty students now I
have to point out something here
initially I Jemma is in part motivated
what will become IgM is in part motive
it by learning by building you could you
know we're out of time where we're
learning about biology over the last
century by taking it apart and seeing
what the parts are but we can also learn
by building and tinkering right and
there's something important about that
as a complementary scientific approach
there's another thing happening here
which is play frivolity in the context
of culture right if I were to begin a
different conversation saying how many
people are totally satisfied with how
biotechnology has gone to market our
culture of biotechnology the politics of
biotechnology do we have it right and
this way of thinking here man the player
woman the player is a way of maybe
reminding us that if we want to get to
the biotechnology we wish for maybe we
have to play and create culture
associated with that first I mentioned
that in passing remember this next
iteration was polka dots well that was a
lot of fun and so we didn't even wait
another year now importantly we got all
the DNA built within a month we'd
actually solved that problem we had
learned it was right to iterate and keep
going
and so we didn't even wait another year
that summer we said let's have some
friends and have fun with our friends so
we got five schools together and it was
called the 2004 synthetic biology
competition and those two folks up in
the front they're now faculty but at the
time students they've got something to
work that's that they build it they got
something working they made
photosynthesis photosensitive eco lights
you can take photographs and plates of
bacteria and I had a nature paper
associate with that so we had a 20
percent success rate in terms of
projects that was cool and so it
happened again
and Randy red Berg the fellow who had
plenty of numbers taught us that if
you're filling a vacuum and we were
filling a vacuum the vacuum we were
filling was nobody was offering a
postmodern curriculum in genetic
engineering you had a world of people
young people who understand that life
has already taken over the planet it's a
nanotechnology that actually works and
jeez if we could only get a little bit
better at engineering it we could make
things but nobody was helping them
on-ramp into that space let alone
acknowledging that we're still even
though there's all these experts and
Nobel laureates in the side the other
thing we're still kind of bad at doing
this so maybe we should work together
again remember that just there's a
market for that you didn't need an
advertising budget to get to that market
just had to be honest so 13 teams came
the next year 40 teams came and Randy
just drove the expansion of this by
being correct the students in 2006
became self-aware
they made a world map of where they were
coming from so that they could figure
out who wasn't having fun with them
southern hemispheres underrepresented
China's missing students travel the
students in China then invited us hey
why don't you come to tangent give us a
primer so here are the top six
universities in China begging us to
spend a weekend with them how could they
participate five of them showed up the
next year the team from peak EU won the
competition got a little bit bigger a
little bigger got a little bit bigger
this is biggest auditorium at MIT so I
won't show you for now the next photos
what are some of the challenges what
happens with our students this is going
to result in the challenge of the world
we wish for versus the world as it
exists so it's hard to quantify this Rob
Carlson the physicist has been tracking
the numbers more than anybody I know and
he represents and now the white house
represents because they're using Rob's
numbers that 40 years after the
invention of genetic engineering
domestically genetically engineered
products on our markets add up to 2% of
our economy it's coarse-grained into
foods medicines and stuff stuff meaning
things like the enzymes in your soap to
make better soap and it's been growing
this is a technology economically that
didn't exist in this product category a
generation ago well our students feed
into this the I gem alumni if you will
feed into this is it what we wish for
think about it differently here are
sectors that our civilization demands if
I unpacked one of these sectors
chemicals and materials this is a
representation from the Department of
Energy how we make the things our
civilization manufactures and consumes
typically on the Left starting from
fossil feedstocks petroleum gas and so
on and then through all the intermediate
chemical processing steps to get to
stuff like this
all right where does all this stuff come
from right we have to make things at
scale they also proposed refactoring the
entire material supply chain for our
civilization so that the left end is not
fossil biology but agile sustainable
biology the living plant
material that we might grow season after
season and what that would look like to
begin to work through that all right
this sets the context for what people
who learn how to engineer biology are
gonna encounter when they graduate so
remember that lady sitting in the front
of the 2003 class that's her there she's
the president of this company ginkgo
buyer works this is half her team they
work in Boston and they represent
themselves as the organism company
people will tell that my wish I had
norges them that does this and then
they'll be ver away and make that
organism and give them that organism
that's their business
right locally with amorous we see
examples of making artemisinin for
treating malaria but also making
biofuels and others compounds with
engineered yeast I like shown here we
know that when we scale up biological
production sometimes things go a little
bit out of whack all right this is the
Sailing location for the Chinese
Olympics the Beijing Olympics right
where you have contaminants coming off
the land into the water and a resultant
bloom of photosynthetic organism from
John hoaxed R World Wildlife we know
that when we deploy biology at scale to
make stuff we have to actually use land
to grow the biology and john represents
to me that we have 24 percent of the
land like what's shown here on the left
this is land capable of growing plants
that's not now under significant human
cultivation the rest of the land that
can grow plants were already tinkering
with so if you want to think about
refactoring the material supply chain
for civilization on top of a sustainable
bio-based manufacturing platform you're
gonna have to figure out where to fit it
in alright do you fit it in by pushing
down the 24% or do you fit it in by
changing our environmental and energy
loads and who's going to figure that out
DuPont right another example sixty
billion dollar company they have six
products on the market now that make
money via genetic engineering their
intention is to shed their entire
petrochemical manufacturing industry and
go entirely bio-based manufacturing
that's their strategy for their third
century of corporate livelihood this
shown here is an indication
of what they're wondering about what
they're wondering about turns out to be
cultural and political freedom to
operate how do we possibly get the
manufacturing capacity our civilization
demands on a sustainable bio-based
footprint how do we make that okay can
we even make that okay they know that
they're dealing with what they call the
snowflake on the tip of the iceberg when
they think about what they make with
biology today so how's this relate to hi
Jim let me try and make the connection
this is an example of an IgM project
that worked the students in Cambridge
England in 2009 were dissatisfied with
the doll brown color of e.coli and so
they ran a project they called a chrome
eye they were able to with 25,000
dollars in capital with 10 teenagers in
16 weeks engineer 7 biosynthetic
pathways making the pigments shown here
from red on the left to purple on the
right how did they do it half the DNA
parts they needed to make these
biosynthetic pathways they got for free
at the start of the summer from the
previous students work in the IgM
BioBricks collection the other half of
the DNA they may need it which was
custom hadn't been done before was
printed for them by DNA 2.0 in Menlo
Park because the founder president of
DNA 2.0 was a graduate of Cambridge gave
them a good deal okay
what would you do with living pigments
they didn't know
they were nerding out right in the lab
so much but at least they recognized
that they didn't know and so they
decided to get help and the help in this
case came from the Royal College of Art
where they went to talk with the
designers the people whose job it is to
imagine products that people don't know
they want wouldn't it be neat if I had a
probiotic yogurt that was instrumented
with genetically encoded sensors it
could go into my gut if I'm healthy what
comes out of me is the normal brown
color but if I'm if I'm out of whack you
laugh but this is gonna be better than a
colonoscopy if I'm out of whack in some
way what comes out will be colored
indicating the disease specialist I
should go see right
the designers called this this catalog
now you'll notice that there's a number
here next to the brand name the brand
names gonna have to change the number is
twenty forty nine this is the year the
designers in London thought we would be
ready
culturally technology we could probably
get to this much faster huh
see how there's a little bit of a
mismatch between food stuff and medicine
and what we might imagine to explore
this coming at a high gem we decided to
Commission a project called synthetic
aesthetics where I basically got a
quarter million dollars and used that to
spend support an artist spending a month
in a laboratory and the bio
technologists and reciprocating and
spending a month in the studio to just
see what else might be out there and
I'll show you real quickly one of those
six experiences sisal to Los shown here
as a perfumer perfume from Berlin and
she worked with Christina a Bacchus than
a microbiologist at Harvard sisal shows
up and she said you know as a perfumer
I'm actually very excited about the
smells of cheese what are you excited
about in the world of microbiology well
at the time and of our time still what's
very exciting in microbiology is what's
called the human microbiome the fact
that they're so many microbes on us and
inside us and they are part of us
well okay let's talk about cheese cheese
has microbes in it and there's a great
cheese shop next to Harvard called for
Maggio's with their own aging cave and
whatnot so they went there in the first
week of their residency and they pulled
core samples of the stinkiest cheese's
and brought that back into the
laboratory in test tubes and they
started streaking out the cheese samples
to see what microbes grew and to do
determinate of bacteriology and all
these cheese microbes but because
they're in a microbiology lab in the
microbiology lab excited about the human
microbiome pretty quickly they have this
conversation to Cristina and sisal and
the conversation goes like hmmm some of
these cheeses are small-batch artisanal
cheeses they're made by human beings who
have hands and who work manually with
the material and on their hands is skin
and on the skin is microbes and there's
microbes in the cheese and what is the
relationship between the cheese
microbiome and the human microbiome and
if you didn't have this tinkering
culture right you'd probably take a
scientific approach of sequence
everything and then use the computers to
line up the patterns and you'd declare
what the relationship is but tinkerers
gonna do things a little bit differently
they're gonna say well we don't know
so let's tinker let's go around the
Harvard campus and collect samples from
our colleagues skin of microbes let's go
to the farm and get raw goat milk
let's inoculate 48 bottles with samples
and then grow some cheese
this all happens this all happens within
weeks so I was passing through Boston
when they brought out the tray of the 48
different cheeses and we had not thought
about safety so we didn't eat the cheese
but we we smelled them and I can
remember still to this day that daisies
armpit cheese is beautiful it is a
citrus floral bouquet as quite stunning
philosopher tochi's you need to invent a
new adjective to describe to describe
how wrong it is what does this have to
do with people and and what we might
wish for my mom said growing up to
finish my green vegetables you know
treat my body as a temple I am what I
eat this project reversed that for me it
said we what we are I was having dinner
that night with a banker from fidelity
and I thought I'd ruin his appetite by
relating the story and he had perhaps
with hindsight predictably just the
opposite he said billion dollar market
celebrity cheese I I believe President
Obama was here recently you could have a
political fundraising cheese you could
have a blue cheese for the Democrats and
so on well let's bring this back to I
Joe another eye gem project these
students were fine with the color of
e.coli they didn't like its bouquet so
they ran a project called ode to Coley
the fecal odor of e.coli can be
correlated with in Dahl they can knock
out bio synthesis of IND all they can
then add in genes and controllers that
lead to while the cells are growing by a
synthesis of methyl salicylate which
gives you a wintergreen bouquet and then
when the cells are in stationary phase
it's a stationary fixed saturated
culture
smells like ISIL amyl acetate or bananas
they got that work in one summer what
would you do with that how does that
change this
what's shown here is how our
civilization works in part implied right
we have centralized manufacturing from
petrol and plant chemicals of this
object which is then physically
transported and then people take it and
they pour it on and represent hopefully
that we smell okay to each other how
about instead I have a website called
high fumes high fumes will allow me to
download DNA sequences for 99 cents the
DNA sequences encode the biosynthetic
pathways to make odorants i fab that DNA
wherever I am locally with my DNA
printer remember we want to separate
design and fab and then I slather that
DNA onto my epidermal ecosystem getting
programmable perfumes still need Brad
need a big bigger marketing budget need
to address issues of safety backwards
and forwards in ways that haven't really
been dealt with yet huh see how we might
change material supply chain see how we
might remove transportation costs right
gets no it's interesting to think about
so one of the things behind this which
is powering I gem is this idea of
standards technical standards that
enable coordination or exploitation of
labor depending on how they're deployed
and I introduced this to you formally
here from an ancient example the
aqueduct in segovia spain where 2,000
years ago people were able to coordinate
labor to make this improbable artifact
note that the artifact the aqueduct is
made from stone but the stone is not
stone found in its native form in the
countryside it's been regularized and
the regularization enables people to
coordinate work in the quarry and the
building site to coordinate work over a
long period of time we could fix this
even today and if you can coordinate
labor you enable things that seem
impossible for individuals to become
quite possible so the impact of
standards if we can make them come true
on engineering living matter or big deal
it creates a type of community that
allows for many things to happen
otherwise totally impossible tech
standards underlying I gem this is part
of synthetic biology there's four things
how you physically organize DNA to put
it together
nights original vibrant standards the
fine example there are many other but
just putting things together isn't what
it's mostly about you want the things
when you put them together to behave as
you expect this is called functional
composition standards for functional
composition how you measure things does
anybody know how long the Golden Gate
Bridge is in miles
what's a mile well we know what's a
kilometer we know how about a smoot some
of you will know but most won't right so
we need to coordinate how we measure
stuff and we need to coordinate how we
represent things so that we can share
information this turns out to be hugely
controversial within the technical
community if you're a professional
researcher working at a company or in a
university trying to get funding to work
on standard biological parts as this is
playing out tough really tough there's
no such thing as a standard biological
part because in biology everything is
context dependent you change the
environment the biology will adapt you
put things together in a novel
combination the biology will adapt it'll
be different this idea that you're going
to be able to type in a sequence of DNA
or we use a part basically and predict
you'll never going to come true
and then other more detailed claims like
ribosome binding sites these are the
control events allow you to print out a
protein inside a cell the idea that
you're going to reuse these the I
gemstones are going to reuse them with
different proteins they're not going to
behave the same these statements are
from really smart people
well-intentioned people who are making
these statements on the basis of a lot
of good reasons I don't have time to go
into what's happened since in great
detail but I'll give you a sense of how
things have been pacing so for example
if I want to do something like this in
my research laboratory at Stanford take
a piece of DNA and flip it and flip it
back and I'm just gonna need to Express
print out three genes inside a cell
today just three genes you know if I
could do this I'd have something like a1
if it's pointing that way in the genome
or zero so this be like a digital data
register zero one register in the
chromosome
when I set out to do that it took us
three years it took us seven hundred and
fifty attempts 750 different DNA designs
to get cells that were zero or could be
switched to one or could stay one or
switch back to zero and so on so this
idea that the biobrick parts are gonna
work perfectly loud that they're like
Legos the critics are in a strong
position when this starts it turns out
that the biggest problem around making
standard biological parts in my
experience was getting money to make
standard biological parts at a market
and I wrote a paper in 1999 asking for
money to make a collection of standard
biological parts and we kept writing and
kept writing and kept writing and in
2009 ten years later we were funded and
so as a joint project between Stanford
and Cal we ran the bio fat pilot in
Emeryville California and we showed that
in fact you could make standard parts
for printing out genes inside cells and
these examples that people had used as
you can never get reliable functional
composition working they're wrong now we
haven't figured this out for everything
but we've gotten to a point where we've
shown that it's not impossible to make
it true the significance of this is a
big deal so remember I said it took me
three years to get good at flipping DNA
once I get good at flipping DNA I can
black box that I can abstract that I can
reuse that with the parts we now have
working well I can do things like this I
can flip other pieces of DNA like this
type of T symbol which is a diode or a
check valve that blocks the reading out
of DNA unless I flip it it's a type of
digital switch I can flip it back we
call this a transcript er and as soon as
we had our DNA flippers we didn't know
we were working on this but we had our
flippers that worked really well and we
put it together in new ways and and then
you know we said what do we do with that
and and we just started looking and we
found this guy from Cork Ireland in the
1850s and you know he was thinking about
stuff like language and how come we have
these words like and' and or' and the
reason we have these words is because
the words like and' and or' are useful
if it's snowing or raining wear my
jacket and so useful are these words
that we implement the equivalent of
these words in any material we can
engineer I happen to be working at a
point on where Ange
in biology so I'm gonna take mr. bull
bully and logic and put that inside a
chromosome and all of a sudden I have a
boolean and game I flipped the first
object and I flipped the second object
and that's an int and we made Hall of
mr. Bulls logic and we made it from
these standard parts and flippers that
took us a decade to get funded and you
know every time we made one of these
systems with our best available
technology the DNA designs work the
first time took us eight weeks 12 weeks
to do the research took us 20 weeks to
publish a paper first time I ever had
off-the-shelf parts working that's 2013
okay
well back to the IBM community they're
not stupid all right they're going we
need to coordinate measurements so let's
get our meter sticks going NIST is now
finally through the Department of
Commerce coming on in developing the
metrology platforms for doing this very
recently a big consortium of people
published a paper on how to share
information they call it the synthetic
biology open language platform I would
say 80 to 90% of the people doing this
type of work are now hi gem graduates if
you will because they've had the
experience of coordination of labor and
of sharing let me zoom out a step
further and try and put this in a
broader context 40 years ago genetic
engineering was invented cut and paste
DNA PCR comes around the same time and
sequencing comes these are the core
tools of genetic engineering what I do
represents is going back a decade now is
let's keep improving our capacity to
navigate the design build test cycle if
we can sustain incremental improvements
our ability to design build test living
systems over time we'll get
geometrically better at engineering life
we've done it with other material we're
going to do with living matter the tools
our synthesis for separating design and
construction
abstraction for managing complexity
standards for coordination of labor and
most importantly let's not stop I don't
know what the other big categories will
be but this is what you see embedded
within I gem thus far the reason this is
important is it poses many challenges I
have no clue what the answers might be
or where they lead to and to introduce
them I'll invoke bill joy so bill is
reported to have said the following no
matter who you are most people work for
some
that's the simple version of Joy's law
that turns out to be true items an
example of this and it's almost more
true than I can imagine in biology and
biotechnology for example most us Mars
biologists aren't gonna work for me this
is relevant because most of biology has
not yet discovered this century we will
discover much of biology still most by
engineers we're gonna tune up the gizmos
I need they don't work for me either the
implicit question enjoys laws so what do
you do about it
at Sun Microsystems the answer was in
part invent Java so that indirectly all
software programmers could work for some
I was interesting at the time well if
other people are discovering them and
we're finding the stuff most of the
parts I want to use are going to be
owned by somebody else most of the needs
and opportunities for what I could make
with biology somewhere else BIOS very
interesting is a distributed
manufacturing platform we have a
civilization has a lot of centralized
manufacturing but think about the bread
machines the yogurt cultures right the
breweries who controls all of that well
mostly won't be you even if you're
dupont
mostly by manufacturing capacity will be
under somebody else's control most of
the problems you're gonna cause are
gonna hurt somebody else
most of the bio tariffs are gonna work
for somebody else right to go back to
what we were wrestling with the decade
ago and I'm sure you could come up with
many other examples of permutations or
variants of choice law so how do we see
this develop in a way that benefits all
people on the planet when I was applying
for a job at MIT we knew did we wanted
to get our students engaged with doing
this work but we didn't know the best
way to do it so my if you pull my file
what I propose doing was starting a
student competition called phage wars
bacterial viruses be engineered by
students to compete with other student
engineered bacterial viruses this was at
the time where you had to have robot
battles on TV it would trigger a very
strong adolescent response it'd be fun
it'd be easy to judge you had all the
different designs to a reactor you'd go
out for dinner you'd come back the next
day and he measure who has the highest
population well yeah you know good thing
we didn't go live with that we
consciously consciously for two reasons
one it prescribes what
might work on which is a big mistake it
doesn't have empathy and allow people to
develop the things they want to develop
for whatever is relevant to them but
also it's it's sort of is it
constructive right is it is it the type
of culture we want to set in motion and
so here's a just an ensemble of
questions we wonder about you know who's
gonna lead biosafety not practiced by a
safety but figure out how biosafety
works what's the plan for biosecurity in
a world where somebody might
intentionally miss apply the tools of
biotechnology remember we shut down our
offensive biological weapons program in
1970 during Nixon administration
just before genetic engineering was
invented hmm how much could we make
right we've got the land-use issues how
much can we make with biology how do we
balance private and public wealth who
gets to choose what's worked on how do
we make this not just be about
industrializing life I don't want to
replace the jungle I want to enable
humanity and nature to flourish together
how do we work on any of this and very
naively here's my assessment of degree
of difficulty of these sorts of
questions you know who has the best
answers to these questions
nobody has good answers but the best
answers are going to come from the iGEM
teams not only because they've been
thinking about it in real time but
because they're collectively a
constructive community that approaches
these questions in a positive way to
begin with
so you know keeping things safe in case
you don't know it our biosafety
framework is coming up on being 40 years
old it was worked out by folks like
Maxine singer David Baltimore Paul Berg
and others down in Pacific Grove and
it's fantastic
but if you look on plots like this and
you just sort of do the time goes by
that's where these folks are and this is
I Jim who's gonna lead biosafety or who
owns all this stuff right so for me I
have a lot of biotechnology I'd like to
see come true I can't do it all I need
to enable many people I would like free
to use language for programming life and
I'm going to work backwards from a
future where that already exists the
reason I take that position is I look at
things like in software where we've got
a whole bunch of
applied systems and I see this bottom
left plot 12 of the 15 most used
computer programming languages are
apparently now free to use they weren't
all developed that way but apparently
it's true now so I'm gonna posit
languages are under positive selection
to become free to use if they're gonna
survive
I want a language for programming life
language is I might as well just start
from that endpoint and work backwards
and figure out how to make it I need a
dictionary of genetically encoded
functions where the uses are free to use
I need a grammar for composing them and
to a first approximation I'm gonna call
this goop which stands for genetic
operations and programs and I'm gonna
want this for an organism to eat sugar
an organism eats methane an organism
eats sawdust an organism eats a light
and also a commensal that lives with us
I'll start with that
well maybe items pioneering this and in
fact they are they have their registry
of parts that they're giving and getting
freely for example this team in
Melbourne Australia made one of my
favorite fabrics ever the gas vesicle
polycistronic gene it's adapted from a
soil microbe that lives in the dirt it's
just over 6,000 base pairs long and this
piece of natural DNA self-assembles when
expressed into the cytoplasm not
consistent here the balloons are
actually inside the cell and fills these
balloons with gas and if you make very
few of the balloons inside your cell the
cell will sink in liquid but if you make
a lot it'll float it'll be buoyant all
right
so within this collection of high gem
associated parts you have tens of
thousands of gizmos who owns all of them
we don't know we don't even know we're
not gonna look because we can't afford
to find out we're just gonna wait until
somebody complains and sends a note and
then what we'll do is we'll delete the
part sort of like a take down but we're
doing this in legal limbo without the
equivalent of the Digital Millennium
Copyright Act which among other things
has this carrier exemption for
intermediaries redistributing stuff we
don't have any of that for biotech you
know we're bootstrapping we're doing
things like through the BioBricks
foundation creating public agreements
with
same lawyers who did the GPL with
Stallman but we can't use copyright and
so we use types of bilateral contracts
and so far we've gotten 19 things out of
limbo and free to use some wonder else
wonderful stuff here like all that logic
stuff we gave away but my favorite is
the fluorescent proteins the things that
make light inside cells which are the
core of our meter stick engine for
measurement DNA 2.0 a company gave those
away there's a lot more work to do and
I'll end with a couple slides giving you
a sense of how people coming from I gem
are now influencing other institutions
if you were to go all over the world to
the top 200 research universities and
ask do you have a program in genetic
engineering that's appropriate for the
21st century most people would point to
an AI gym team and the legacy of the
iGEM team if the students when they go
back can't find a faculty member
oftentimes to advise them they'll
oftentimes go to the provost and say you
need to hire somebody right if you look
at the most interesting companies to me
now operating in biotechnology coming
through Y Combinator and other programs
these are the companies that aren't yet
making a lot of money but they have the
transactions right around sharing and
specifying what to make and then
partnering with business to business
networks they're coming out of the iGEM
graduates at Stanford shown here just a
couple months ago we've completed our
first bioengineering building it's the
first time in ten years I've worked in a
building with the word bio engineering
on the outside and the whole first floor
of this building is set up as an I gem
studio I retired from my gym about five
years ago so I could work on this and I
could work on what might become I gem
2.0 the IBM tech platform is a decade
old think about running a software
competition on the software tools of a
decade ago hmm we've got a lot of work
to do if you want to learn more I would
strongly encourage you to make your way
to Boston Massachusetts for Halloween at
the hinds Convention Center the big
Civic Convention Center there will be
the giant Jamboree celebrating the tenth
year
of iGEM they're expecting 2,500 3,000
students talking about what they're
doing what they're vibrating about we
know biology can make a lot of stuff
we're not yet very good at partnering
with biology to make things and the
culture of biotechnology is far from
perfect in the public sphere how do we
figure it out playing and making go
together we've shown it's not impossible
to make biology easier to engineer and
though I agree regarding predictions if
you were to ask the engineering
community what do we imagine our legacy
to be for this century it seems likely
that that legacy is we're making living
matter engineer Apple the secret is to
get better and better and better at
navigating that process of design build
test oh by the way it won't all work so
we'll learn about life by tinkering and
play why do this well if we pull it off
right we enable all constructed biotech
not in a top-down controlled way but in
a grassroots distributed organic way
ironically and if that's done correctly
we have a chance of renewing our
civilization and partnership with nature
enabling both to flourish and hopefully
you remember that synthetic aesthetics
example it's not just the nerd rapture
right this is creative design this is
ethics this is the Enlightenment thanks
very much look forward to conversation
with you and Stuart
[Applause]
Bob Copa gasps what could possibly go
wrong when high-school students are
making new life at home
nothing nothing they're under strong
negative selection to not do things
wrong
what do you mean negative selection
what's the negative so they all die when
they do it wrong that's right so there's
a cover of the Boston newspaper in 1977
right at the time when I believe it was
Cambridge the City Council had outlawed
genetic engineering and the newspaper
cover said botulism soup and had a
mock-up of a Campbell's soup can and on
the label it said recombinant DNA and
then in that magazine
they had instructions for how to clone
the toxin gene in your kitchen and you'd
have the soup what's interesting is to
my knowledge nobody did that now that's
because either nobody did it or those
people were under negative selection
either way selfish so but but
importantly I think it's because nobody
did it right I don't be naive about it
but but you know we do have a topic of
biosecurity biosafety as a topic of
culture we can handle it and perfectly
but well enough and we're gonna have to
take some risks to do anything so it's
okay might as well have seemed stupid
died off right you said that the real
puzzle to me true is that coming up on
ten years biotech is big news big money
but I Jim has been the least reported
tectonic phenomenon I know of and it's
like it's almost shunned as by media and
by you know sort of the general public
as if
they don't want to think about it or I
don't know what's going on I mean if you
know they'll finally catch on in that
Burning Man is amazing and you know word
gets out of them pretty soon there's a
lot of attention being paid to that one
and we'll have a talk from Larry Harvey
pretty shortly telling a similar story
to yours I think but I Jim still huge as
it is global as it is feels like some
closely kept a secret yes no okay um how
was the computer network being discussed
in 1983 we have a biotech network
emerging it's a decade old it's not that
old
hmm within the political and policy
leadership it's well known hi Jim mm-hmm
I think one of the puzzles with respect
to the corporation show up the
government show up who comes to you
think government say more Minister will
it's the late just resigned minister of
universities and research in the UK
studied ijen backwards and forwards and
is basically directing hundreds of
millions of pounds in public investment
to make sure that Britain doesn't become
a museum of 19th and 20th century
technologies right fully powering high
gem throughout the country so you do
have cases of civic leadership he's an
outlier you you at least in the US I've
not found a politician who says part of
the future will involve biotechnology we
need to figure out how to talk about
genetic modification as part of our
civic life we don't have that type of
leadership here there is another aspect
though to return to your question
directly which makes Civic awareness of
this difficult to sustain most of the
press coverage triggers just an
overreaction within the messaging so a
good example would be Foreign Affairs
there issue the last issue of 2013
biology's brave new world is the cover
story be happy and worried right and
then picks up on things like eye gem to
say we're going to save the world and
destroy the world simultaneously it's
both the Rousseau Ian view and the
Hobbesian view of the state of nature
and state of man and there's nothing in
the
I call this the the political or public
messaging halfpipe of doom or a sort of
people get pulled back and forth between
these extremes and the reason that's
problematic is because a it's not true
but but B it consumes all the bandwidth
for communication and the more
interesting conversations that build up
in the middle don't happen at all right
so somehow we have to when people go
around saying they're creating life when
they're reconstructing genomes mm-hmm
you know and how about we just talk
about what's happening you know and that
that's not happening because of the
polarization of the of the conversation
I would say we see polarization in many
dimensions right it's not just promise
in parellel it's for or against things
aren't so cleanly digital right and
again you have to get to the messy
middle so something about messaging
hasn't got to that yet so the messy
middle is occupied by the tinkerers by
the makers and the players but the messy
middle doesn't you're saying get become
part of the public discourse yeah so
what are you doing about that not
worrying about it I'm here right I mean
but what do you want me to do about it
you know I think I think one of the go
mera come on no okay so so you know what
the meta is we give out stickers so so
we had a big problem when I Jim got
bigger in that we want to celebrate what
people are doing what have fun and so we
give up prizes in probably the president
well he went from 13 teams to 40 teams
we made the mistake of running out of
prizes and we only had 20 prizes and so
that man half the teams didn't get
recognized within the peer group and
that felt bad so the innovation was
medals you could come to hi Jim and you
could earn a bronze medal a silver medal
or a gold medal and it's not like the
Olympics in that we declared we had an
infinite number of medals everybody was
eligible for medals but to earn a medal
you had to satisfy the requirements
right you had to
design a biobrick part to earn Doubront
yet to improve or measure a by brick
part to earn a silver you had to give
back a part to earn a gold and you had
to do other things for gold like address
a policy issue
all right many requirements for gold
next thing you knew many people wanted
gold medals or stickers and the reason
that's relevant is they would then go
home and we'd start after the iGEM
Jamboree to follow what was coming up on
the news feeds and there'd be a
newspaper report from Texas somewhere
and they'd say team from Texas A&M goes
to MIT and earns gold medal right or
team from Jinja and university or earns
gold medal at MIT right and so it was a
local press coverage that seemed more
interesting right so that was that was
going meta and scaling stickers which
greatly and so I think the next thing is
to hand out stickers or medals in those
three categories to reporters based on
the quality of do they engage the gray
that's interesting and do they you know
go they talk to an actual student or
things like that
it's a good suggestion and given the
fact that people are spending a lot of
money to reinvent what journalism looks
like it makes sense to me I haven't seen
any of that built into feels investments
or the night program for journalism it
makes good sense we have to rescue breda
that type of journalism since it's free
I'll take ten percent
a version of this tum keema asks what do
you tell tea party people what do you
tell people who are ultra conservative
in some sense and all of this seems
really dubious it seems dubious well I
don't know maybe that's not the word
what is it what do you think back in the
day you communist DNA it was gonna cause
botulism there was a you know there was
a reaction that had this kind of quality
to it yeah whatever you're doing do it
huh what do you say for moral reasons
for religious reasons for safety reasons
okay probably are you playing God and
the answer is you know the only time
that's ever come up is when I went home
for the holidays
mmm and I have on my father's side three
aunts who are formidable ladies very
smart good bridge players and devoutly
religious and they asked me well why are
you doing all this what's wrong with the
DNA that God gave us a good question and
and I thought about it for a little bit
I asked them have you looked and now
they want to get sequenced well that's
nice once people are sequenced do they
engage and and start to feel that this
is their sign it's not something that
could be okay I like that you know me
too okay Chris camp wants to know is it
plausible scientifically and financially
to create a caffeinated banana
so you can do biosynthesis of
biosynthesis of morphine it's worked out
not morphine caffeine morphine two
different type of banana what I don't
what I don't know is Stewart and to the
to the question is I don't know how
difficult it would be to get that
operating in a banana and I presume
that's doable but I can't I couldn't
even give you an estimate on the fly of
what that would cost
okay skip the banana how about just
intermediating poppies but you have done
in the news today you know you want to
explain that and who's involved in what
that portends conflicted it's my wife
and she has a team that's worked for a
decade now on biosynthesis of the benzo
lights qua an alkaloid family of
chemicals it's a fancy word for things
grown in opium poppies so morphine and
and other stuff and it's a complicated
pathway of order 20 steps so much more
complicated than what most IBM teams
would work on and they seem to have
opened that up so remember the Hoda cold
project and Brad Pitt and perfumes and
thinking about rerouting material supply
chains what does it mean to do the same
for basically anything made in a plant
and I would anticipate if you want to
consider the puzzle that that it becomes
possible within the next few decades not
just for the BIA is the ventilator loads
but most plant natural products we don't
have good tools for doing net
assessments around for example changes
in land use is it better or worse to
grow a poppy on a field or sugar cane in
another field and then reroute stuff and
then obviously there's control around
the Tyrael supply chains right so all
sorts of stuff caffeinated yeast I think
one of an IgM team project already done
caffeinated bananas they're interesting
other sorts of things you know someone
met a question here from Connor what is
the weakest leg of the current design
build test cycle measurement say it
again there's measurement right there's
a lot of things you'd like to measure
inside living systems most of the
measurement technologies we have now
destructive which means you have to grow
a lot of the cells or organism up and
then grind it up and put it on an
instrument like a mass spec or something
that basically separates out the bits
and pieces and tries to quantify it so
so we you know you know that first Apple
thing that came in the wooden box from
Steve and Steve you could hook it up to
a display but imagine if you didn't even
have that right and that's kind of how
we're operating it's desperately needed
to basically make wetware to measure
wetware so you can build in ways of
quantifying what's happening inside a
cell and have a cell tell you what it's
doing with light so that's why for
example those flippers are nice there's
other types of tools for genetically
encoded sensors that then transduce
things into light so test here's a way
to quantify it so i teach i used to
teach the laboratory course at stanford
in the new bioengineering major so we
have sophomores they have no
prerequisites they have to design build
test a living system this is how I'm pro
- typing item 2.0 it takes us four weeks
to design with the students who've never
taken genetics and come up with a three
thousand base pair design takes us two
weeks to get the DNA built at DNA 2.0 in
Menlo Park and it takes us the rest of
the quarter six weeks to test and that's
where most of the failure is designs we
always get to designs 90% of our DNA is
built successfully now and 25% we get
good measurements all right so you look
at a company like Agilent for example
the legacy of Hewlett Packard not
coincidentally they're shedding their
hardware business which I believe to be
a mistake but they're to focus on
bio-based measurement right for their
future so measurement is the hardest in
my opinion inexperienced a larger
measure is sort of the one that goes
along with things like Moore's law the
doubling of some named capacity every
two years
is there any equivalent like that in
synthetic biology do you think it's
represented with different brands
neither well-established Carlson curves
after Rob Carlson the tracking of the
cost down and capacity increase for DNA
sequencing
and DNA synthesis both the reading and
writing of DNA improving faster than
computer chips are getting better the
significance of those two tools together
is they make genetic material genetic
information interconvertible
right so you'd have a physical object of
DNA you can move that with sequencing
the information on a network and then
redesign it and remake it with synthesis
somewhere else so that's important for
basically remix in information location
but in this case it's important to drive
distributed manufacturing it's why - ziz
not merely a crazy fantasy you could
actually have online resources telling
you what DNA sequences make what things
and then have that flow as information
and manufactured locally all right so if
you're if your company like to pod for
example to use them as an example right
they're dealing with three large
dimensions of ambiguity is the future
biotechnology going to be accepted or
not politically is there going to be
distributed manufacturing or centralized
manufacturing and is there going to be
distributed innovation or centralized
innovation and all of those are for
grabs
really centralized innovation could
happen it sounds like it's too late
thanks guys
they have a certain posture all right
now which is more aligned with central
well it's so decentralized in terms of
but all I meant to say was right we're
you know that that cost down on read and
write of DNA is what's pushing
decentralization and making that more
and more feasible for buying nectar so
we got 3d printers DNA prayers at home
coming along soon
maybe maybe not but in your neighborhood
seems fine sort of like I heard you know
we don't all need lawn mowers but one
lawn mower per neighborhood might be a
good idea I don't think everybody needs
one
I do like for example things like meth
anyt rose these are organisms that eat
methane in part because we have natural
gas pipes coming into most of our houses
and so if I had an organism that eats
methane as yeast eats sugar but what
about an organism eats methane I could
have those organisms make food my gas
goes to food I could have those
organisms make plastics for the printers
all right so so you know I don't think
everybody needs a DNA printer but uh but
a physical material printer maybe and
you could do distributed manufacturing
of that printer cartridges basically the
feedstocks are the printers the
salvation' supposedly of a lot of
environmental badness that goes out from
our manufacturing system salvation is
supposed to be green chemistry mmm
fewer solvents lower temperatures better
energy efficiency all of that is all of
this moving in the direction of green
recovery if we do it right mmm yes if we
do it right I mean Joanna Eisenberg's
work with the Venus flower basket sponge
when she was at Bell Labs looking at the
organic biosynthesis of meaning biology
driven biosynthesis of fiber optic
cables made out of silica is happening
in the ocean at environmental conditions
by definition so so biology as a
materials manufacturing platform for
making high by abiotic objects or things
like teeth you know but but glasses
metals seems pretty doable as why Tom
Knight got into biotechnology as an
electrical engineer right so he was um
as an electrical engineer looking ahead
and and saying as our feature sizes on
chips get smaller and smaller and
smaller these semiconductor materials
have dopant atoms in the silicon and
we're relying on random or Poisson
distribution or dispersion of the dopant
atoms that's fine so long as the average
number is pretty high per per device
feature but as as what we're making is
tiny tiny entire that average number it
goes low which means sometimes just by
chance what you think as a semiconductor
isn't a simpler way to think about this
is making chocolate chip cookies all
right so if you're making big chocolate
chip cookies that have on average 100
chocolate chips for cookie that means
it's a hundred plus or minus ten hundred
plus or minus square root of a hundred
chips for cookie but if I'm making nine
chips per cookie nine tackle chips per
cookie is nine plus or minus square root
of nine or three if I have really tiny
chocolate with cookies I have on average
only one chocolate chip or cookie it's
one plus or minus the square root of one
which means a third at time I have
chocolate chip cookies with no chocolate
chips they're not chocolate of cookies
and so the same problem appears in in
hardware engineering
and to solve the problem you have to put
atoms in particular locations how do you
put atoms in particular locations Tom's
conclusion was biology does that we have
to get good at partnering with biology
to make hardware is there any
nanotechnology left outside of our
technology do you think I mean in this
sense you're using biotech to make these
computers the computational stuff you
know remember nanotech was gonna change
the world
yeah and did that just go away because
it's actually all biotech no I don't
think so I mean I think there's a there
there but you also have to represent
that national nanotechnology initiative
in the United States launched under the
Clinton administration is a political
activity right as much as anything else
so they undertake it's money biotech
doesn't what do you think we've not yet
seen the equivalent of that I'm not
arguing for that per se but I'm just
when I return to nanotechnology it was
driven in a different way it was driven
in a top-down way with very strong
political leadership and what I'm
representing here is not the same
globally I mean the one thing that I
think semi spooks aren't delights people
is that IBM teams are not just us not
just us in Europe not just us Europe and
Asia but all over Helen going how does
that play out does it mean that for
example that some countries will resist
biotech and and you know that it doesn't
matter because other countries will have
a lot of IBM students that will carry it
to the frontier and then everybody else
will have to take one of the great
things about science in general is that
it's common across humanity oftentimes
and you know when you're coming up as a
student you typically don't experience
this it's not till you're you know
established that you get to go to these
international meetings and wouldn't you
know it
right at this level of high school and
college we're giving people the best
international community for this science
and so I think one of the things items
students experience is they are part of
a global community of
people who intend to do good and it's
not that any one person knows what the
right thing to do is but you have trust
among your ensemble of colleagues your
community that people are trying to do
the right thing where they are and I
think having that experience very early
is hugely important so what would the
IgM students all sort of know about each
other cohort bar cohort are they all
connected through the ten year
band of population now yeah Jim the I
Jim Foundation you know you can pull
their annual report Randy and Meghan and
the whole team there it does just a
heroic amount of work on a shoestring of
a budget and so all the things you would
expect to exist right if anything exists
at all is because somebody sweated it
out right and just made it happen and
most of this is not yet mature or fully
developed so you know where's the IgM
alumni program well gosh we know we want
it we've got 20,000 of them right but
who's got time for that and who's
helping with that and you know you know
how about retired gem right it's one
thing to be working with college
students but how about people just
retired there's a lot more than coming
maybe we could start I gem team someday
right we could be on a team together so
so so you know I think there's you know
check it out all right it's hugely
impressive what they pulled off and the
fact that it exists at all is improbable
and you know a lot more could be done
well it's keeping its life and keeping
going one final question from Ollie
Blakely how much does science fiction of
popular culture influence young
scientists where do the science fiction
fit into all of this because we keep
hearing the de-extinction all those
science fiction is Jurassic Park and we
say well yes and no and but in fact
we're able to talk about the extinction
because of Michael Crichton
and Steven Spielberg doing something a
number of years ago where
science-fiction play into this
population and its expectations and
they're doing science reality but it's
pretty fantastic so their stories being
told somewhere in there that's a good
question
you know Rudy Rucker uh-huh right real
where free where somebody we read kind
of liked the idea of the maldis mm-hm
you know fungal manufacturing that seems
coming not everything he says but okay
Roger Brandt who is a mentor for a time
a huge fan of science fiction had the
biggest science fiction live I've ever
seen he would organize meetings and Greg
bear would be there
mmm-hmm you know and I remember going to
by Darwin's radio Big Bear right I think
so right somebody did somebody check
that the good bug I remember being in
biosphere 2 with Greg and we were taking
a tour and this is the facility in
Arizona where they had a enclosed
environment earth being biosphere one
bias or tubing this experiment to live
inside a closed environment for a while
and really wasn't close so they they
have this bladder a huge bladder for
containing the atmosphere is you have
expansion contraction during the heat
load during the day cooling at night and
to get to the bladder you had to walk
through this semi-submerged steel tube
that was eight feet in diameter we're
walking through it and for reasons I had
no idea in the middle of this tube is
this odd it's like Ace of Spades shape
keyhole that you have to step over I was
walking right in front of Greg and he
quips now we know what the people who
built this facility looked like so so
that's been wonderful you know people
like rudy and greg new blood music and
and other stuff we've implemented blood
music technically in my lab now except
they haven't taken over and destroyed
things and which is good and you know so
that's all fantastic but the flip side
of this
is which is horrible if you go to then
this comes back to the media
representation you're asking about and
you go down Southern California and you
look at what the products are that are
shipping I say how's the movie coverage
of the future of biotechnology that we
dream for and imagine Gattaca contagion
Gweneth does not do well in container
that's released right you laugh at
damnit that's released on September 11th
2011 to the day so so you know on the
one hand it's fantastic but on the other
hand we don't have like a movie I
appreciate is contact right who knows
about the aliens but at least in contact
we have a plausible heroic narrative
engaged with humanity some of the people
are not great the director of the NSF in
that story mm-hmm not such a nice guy
but Jodie Foster's character is a
heroine and and we don't have the
storytelling for reasons I don't I'm not
excited about I'd like to think I'd
actually like to work on this one we
don't have the storytelling capacities
thriving in the marketplace around what
I'll call realistic heroic narratives
that don't collapse to some egocentric
maniac right you know but are more
representative of this reality of we've
got a community and and we need that
desperately for biotech and the absence
of that you know III return to people
tend to try and do what we can imagine
and if we don't have the capacity to
tell stories that are the positive
constructive realistic heroic narratives
for the future biotech what do you like
it or not we're understanding more about
the living world that's part of our time
and we're getting a currently better at
engineering a living matter that's part
of our time so so you before against
that but but you have to help us figure
out what we wish for and it doesn't you
know you were saying something before
the talk about optimism and pessimism
you want to say that again and we'll
call it a night
sure so I had an experience as a PhD
student in a course called science
technology and society it was for PhD
students and each week a different
person would come and see everett Koop
just retired a Surgeon General
he'd come in and talk about healthcare
and professor Kantrowitz I believe it
was amazing engineer he came in to talk
to us about sustainability and we are
all very excited all four of us were
very I went to do my engineering work at
Dartmouth which you think of as an
undergraduate liberal arts college but
damn it's a great place for engineering
because there's no departments it's just
one school of engineering Without
Borders inside and they just let you do
whatever you want with high expectations
and this fellow showed up to talk about
sustainability and we were super excited
and Denny he ambushed us he said
sustainability is is just a disaster
it's the most dangerous thing I've ever
encountered
where's what are you talking about
there's a finite planet and you know
life's only got ninety terawatts of
juice flowing through it in terms of
energy we've got to figure how to make
things move oh you mean with
sustainability is the responsible path
you're not hearing what I'm saying it's
very dangerous it's the worst thing ever
okay what do you mean and he said well
my my job here today is to explain two
things to you
number one pessimism is a
self-fulfilling prophecy
number two optimism is a self-fulfilling
prophecy thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you